okay I was glad that a lot of people
were yesterday we were able to get real
output because it makes a difference
between the first time night gear that
all you get is error messages and the
next time and and all of a sudden you
get something that that that that looks
great all of a sudden it's it's a lose
bigger you win big it seemed when you're
starting with these things and also the
but the main thing is uh and that's a
whole subject of our discussion today is
going to be about error messages and and
why the computer says such stupid things
back to you now when you're dealing with
something but when you do with somebody
else you it always helps to to have a
little empathy with them of course but
also to understand their point of view
and especially a computer if you
sometimes it all makes sense if you can
only understand that the computers
peculiar point of view and so what I
want to try to explain today is is a
little bit about about how how tech look
set at the world you have to realize
here is this port computer program
sitting there and a lot of people trying
to do things with it you know and maybe
it's a little tired maybe it's maybe it
doesn't understand what you're trying to
do it doesn't know too much mathematics
you you know I it knows a little bit of
about spacing but sometimes that get it
somebody says something else and and
sometimes your error messages don't seem
to make very much sense to you because
because what you type made very good
sense to you and it also made very good
sense to tech unfortunately completely
different completely different sense
this this to a certain extent is
inevitable with with any with any
powerful tool on the other hand if
there's if if everyone if if tech were
designed simply to handle
student exercises for a class like this
then we think we would engineer it
differently so that it it would
recognize certain error messages yeah so
we recognize certain error messages and
and and recover from them the kind of
messages that are often done innocent
soon again to go to my office and find a
piece of paper that has a 40 on the
upper right hand corner I seem to have
forgotten to bring it excuse me so so
you know in other words that in this
course we have one we have one set of
applications for tech and these are in
and these are pretty much to use the
basic format and to and to do technical
typing the tech also is used for many
other things and a lot of different
computers in the system that we have now
is not is not optimized particularly for
for exactly this class so so that's so
in order to understand its point of view
are you first want to want to see how so
what it is so what's when text starts
out you say run tech and and there and
and it's it comes at your service but at
this point it's what a philosophers
would probably say it tabula rasa or
something like this it really doesn't
know very much it's ready to do your
bidding but it doesn't know even what a
becks it doesn't even know that that
backslash is is going to be the escape
symbol it doesn't know that a dollar
sign is going to be used for mathematics
and doesn't use it doesn't know what any
of the special other characters that
you're doing it because it's set up to
be general purpose it could be used on
there are lots of different keyboards
and and so for example the very first
thing you type to it it seems it's going
to be your escape character like the
backslash so if the first thing you type
is not a backslash then then it then it
says ok that's going to be the backslash
from not
and then so typically the first thing
you type then is a backslash okay and
then you say input or something else
okay so that's one well now that now
when if you if the first thing that you
type is input basic then it reads in the
file called basic and the very first
thing that basic does is it tells it
that dollar sign is going to be used for
mathematics and in a down arrow for
subscripts and things like that that's
the very if you have to know exactly if
you want to see exactly what basic has
its appendix in the manual appendix B
and very first two lines of that
appendix are all full of funny-looking
things called code and chicon is a is a
way of defining what is a left brace
what is what begins the group what what
what's used for subscript superscription
things like that so so without that
information tech doesn't know what to do
also that's also at the beginning it
doesn't know any it doesn't have any
fonts it doesn't doesn't you haven't
told it the names of any funds so as far
as it knows there aren't any fonts in
the world so so after you input basic /
basic has has told it that about 13
useful fonts of type and also has has
has defined that your current font is a
particular one that will be used for for
Roman type you know not boldface not a
telling so so it helps to at the very
beginning then Tech has it has to has to
build up to a certain to a certain level
of competence and just by typing back /
input basic then you built it up to
quite it's quite a thing well and I
could of course have made a special
version of tech that would just start
out with what it knows after input basic
but but but a lot of people after they
after they want to use it for other
things they'll have something else
beside basic of basic is too basic for
them and so that and and I have other
keyboards or something so the general
purpose system is set up to adapt itself
so that's one of the reasons for the
the first funny error messages that you
get in fact I used to think that the on
that the shortest way that you could
that you could call that you cause tech
to go to a screeching halt was this this
is something that that's some of you I
know came up with you see if we can
focus on this and get get not now i'm
going to be showing you a lot of errors
that temp of listings of errors temp
files today and unfortunately when you
print an error start temp file at the
moment there is something that we
haven't fixed that is after i typed in
put paper the line feed between the
carriage return and making it go to the
next line got dropped and so it the two
line listed on top of each other but
what actually should have been in the in
the air temp file is it is input paper
and then it says paper tech 12 that
means it's starting to read the file
called paper TX and it read page one in
the case of the sale system that was
just a directory page and read page two
it started to read page two and then it
said whoa you have to define a font
first now probably a lot of you have
seen this message and say what in the
heck is going on and then it says images
it just stops essentially at this point
now and and the error message occurred
on page 2 line one in other words the
very first the very first line of the
other that of that file because page one
is ignored and and also when you get an
error message first of all there's this
! and and the error message itself then
then come the 22 lines saying where they
are occurred the first line is what tech
is already read the second line is what
tech is going to read next so all a tech
is red is at capital t just a capital T
was the very first thing in that in that
file paper and and so what happened well
what's going on looks like you can see
the first thing tech red was a capital T
that means it's supposed to typeset a
a tea and at the end it doesn't even
know that there are any fonts in the
world you have an input basic or
anything so so it there's nothing it can
do so I just quits says woe and and
screeching halt okay now that's that I
but you're not smiling I everybody's
upset about the fact that it does this I
see okay now but but the other day I I
noticed that there was an even even
faster way to cause tech to crash and
that was a person were very reasonably
started out said run tech and then it
prints an asterisk and okay well there
are a lot of computer programs that have
two prints nastiest and you're supposed
to give a name of a file so just so here
was the result after seeing the asterisk
type paper tech and it says whoa you
have to define a font first now that was
now this is very interesting to me
anyway maybe not to you that it would
crash so fast on that and in this way
look what it's red it's red the PA and
not PE up now on anybody figure that out
this is really kind of strange okay well
I know this is like Ellery Queen you
know you've got all the clues you hurry
the P it's been defined as the Hippias
been defined as the escape character
okay so it looks like a backslash detect
so the second p is another like a
backslash okay so so now it's picked up
back /a essentially okay so back /a it
turns out to be a Scandinavian accent I
get to give you that clue
but this is and so we read just the PA
and stop there you see after seeing that
back /a which was seeing a type an
accent which is which is again you have
to be you have to have some fun before
in order to type in accent so it stopped
there and again and again stuff okay now
that's the message and i found one other
example of a wall message in the files i
was spying on and it was here this was
in a this was in a this was in something
that was a more complicated one than
most of you will be doing because it was
using somebody else it was used another
thing and then i had a whole bunch of
definitions at the beginning and there
was a typo in the definitions here this
is a definition of a control sequence v
bar DN and and and actually the braces
weren't nested so that the definition
ended right here and so so the text
after here was not part of a definition
I mean a person had had meant to had
meant to have braces around this whole
business but then so I've got into some
text and it started with getting into a
into a you know making a box in math
molten math formula and again it said
you had to have a font first so in
general when you get this message war
you have to define a font first that
usually means that you that you haven't
gotten tech properly started like but in
putting basic or getting all of your
definitions in there oh you started to
you started to get into text before you
ever told that what the what fonts you
were you were doing or getting it
started hey now the the next thing I
gotta tell okay so what now I guess I
should explain this asterisk so you
start running tech and it gives you an
asterisk what does that mean that means
it's time for you to tell it what to do
and if you are just type of carriage
return ill give you another asterisk
tell me something to tell me what to do
it so asterisk from tech means give me
some give me some input now I think the
best way to understand tech is a little
bit in
humanoid terms that is I like to think
that the tech having an input mechanism
are two input mechanisms one which will
call its mouth and one which will call
it its stomach so the thing first goes
into the mouth and gets gets suggested a
little bit and then not digested but
masticated a little bit and then the and
then then the stomach takes over and and
those other things and then comes the
output the I think you can understand
analogy not now perhaps I should have
tried so welcome anyway now the the
mouth is a little bit like eyes too but
anyway it's because it we also say it's
reading your in your instruction did you
find a gym oh great perfect perfect okay
good i left this in my office and that
was i was just about ready to so anyway
the asterisk is it tells you that it
once it wants to you to tell it what to
do now one thing you could do is you
could type in the names of fonts and you
could type in chi codes telling it what
what the dollar signs are going to be
used for math forum and things like that
if you wanted to you could type it in
right after asterisk it'll take any
instructions there but if those things
are already on the computer somewhere
else then you can then you can say
backslash input and give the name of the
file and then it will read in will go it
will go to that file as a convenience
that you don't have to retype this stuff
over and over again but if you wanted to
you could type everything after an
asterisk okay so when you say back /
input basic this is just an abbreviation
for typing in the whole of the file
basic one line at a time after these
asterisks which we police would come in
okay and then if now here's an example
of one of the people had had actually
actually entered a lot of things then
after asterisks input basic came in
first and then then it read in basic one
two three four red
in the right parenthesis there meant
that it got to the end of file basic and
then it gives another asterisk this
person that at this point the person
typed back / H size 11 inches
incidentally rather wide for align with
this is the line with not counting
margins and paper is only eight and a
half inches wide in the first place so
so if you've got an inch margins you
only have six and a half so there's this
is a rather long line but anyway this is
a this this is the instruction in tech
guy is of course we've set up to to
produce output for photo typesetters
that have that can type set newspaper
they can take long line so it doesn't
mind 11 inches in and then we have
actually very beautiful text coming in
here but you notice that it's coming in
after asterisks this is the era thought
my lists essentially a transcript of
what happened as you as you type and so
the and so here we have a beautiful
beautiful passage and and now this is
then going to be going into tech and
tech is it is accepting it line but line
at a time and actually what happens is
this is a good example to tell you about
text modes and you might also think of
moods if you're not used to mode but I
guess modes is coming into fashion now I
mean I was reading a when William
sapphires count the other day about
everybody in Washington is talking about
such and such a mode of some so I guess
it's coming in to the to the English
language but anyway you mean computer
jargon is proliferating but I didn't
even think I got it I think I knew about
modes when I was young but I don't
remember anyway Tech is has you
different modes of operation and it's
like moods in other words it's ready for
a certain kind of stimuli and it'll sort
of not be ready for some for the other
one and the basic three modes that take
has are the vertical mode the horizontal
mode and the mathematics mode now teka
is a mission in life the mission in life
is to produce is to produce pages of
output and these but the way it reviews
that is that is that the is to construct
boxes what it calls boxes it's a funny
word but it's really two dimensional
boxes but it considers a page is a box
of which is break broken down as a list
of other boxes and and each in so a box
is either a letter by itself or or
something like a black rectangle or a
line rule or something like that that's
indivisible or the box you can look
inside it and you'll find more boxes and
you find a list of other boxes and you
have either a horizontal list of boxes
or vertical list of boxes so typical
page is a box that was broken down into
a list of lines stacked on top of each
other so that's a vertical list and then
these mines themselves are boxes that
were our horizontal lists that are that
were built from left to right you know
and made up but ultimately you come down
to the atoms of this thing that don't
divide anymore and those are individual
letters a sope text mission is really to
build up boxes by making either lists of
horizontal things or vertical things and
at any time if know it what it thinks it
wants to do next is add to one of its
lists either it's in if it's in
horizontal mode it will add something to
a horizontal list what it's called and
if it's in vertical mode it has to a
vertical list now that's one way of
thinking about it and another maybe more
intuitive way is to saying that vertical
mode is when it's once to add something
to the page and horizontal mode is when
it wants to add something to align okay
because in vertical mode it's building
something in a vertical direction in
horizontal mode is adding is going this
direction now the the mathematics mode
is what you get into between dollar
signs so those are the three the three
basic modes that that tech has it starts
out in vertical mode it means it's ready
to add something to a page and when you
type a letter letter T or something in
vertical mode it says well what's this
letter doing here it looks to me like
something like start of a paragraph and
so immediately
in the horizontal mode and puts and puts
in the indent for the paragraph in the
tea and your paragraph has started out
with an indentation and a tee and then
you stay in horizontal mode until you
get to a blank line or a PA r which says
that was the end of a paragraph okay so
so we're in horizontal mode means in a
paragraph or in a line something going
horizontal okay so we're starting out
and let's take a look at this this
transcript and see what happens then so
input basic puts us in vertical mode
we're in vertical more at the beginning
we input the basic and we're still in
vertical mode then we gave about
instruction about age size still in
vertical mode okay now these skip is
something you can say in vertical mode
it's vertical skip the vertical skip so
you can do if you try to say H skip in
vertical mode would say something is
wrong you're trying to skip horizontally
but I'm in vertical mode I'm trying to
build something vertically so no I will
I think that actually happens down below
okay so anyway you say V skip so it says
okay that's nice you put a use use use
you you leave an inch of space now
another thing I have to I have to
mention though is that at the top of a
page any skipping that you do is ignored
because because there's another
adjustment that tries to get to the top
baseline on a page in a particular place
so you'd have to you'd have to put at
least a box containing nothing and
something in before you do a V skip and
we have something called top it's tops
at there's a control sequence in basic
nowadays that that you can use to get
space at the top of a page but now
usually between pages the space is if
any space that was that was there gets
gets eliminated between pages exactly as
in a paragraph if there's a space
between words that space gets eliminated
when you go from one line to the next
and so that the rules / horizontal and
vertical are essentially the same now ok
so anyway then love came along
centerline centerline love now center
line is something that that builds a
that that makes an H box if you look at
what center line is actually does inside
a tech it's an H box that's that's also
centered and the width of the H box is
the width of the line so this is going
to be an H box a horizontally built box
it's 11 inches wide and and it's going
to be centered so that so it'll be there
will be the letters l.o.v.e and then and
then filler put to the left and right so
that so that those come out centered in
fact if you want to look at the output
here it is it doesn't look centered but
that's because you're only seeing the
first seven and a half inches of this 11
inch line okay now you know don't laugh
you make mistakes too no no this is a
this is just to show you that the
machine is going to methodically I guess
it is funny in a way because the road of
the robot was funny when she would obey
orders exactly on on those old TV shows
right now okay so Vee skip okay so
centerline makes a box and then then but
and then gives it to tech well tech deck
was in vertical mode and when you give
techs in vertical mode it's okay I'll
put that on into my vertical list and
keep on going so that box got got that
was the whole line of ours that got
added and got to the current page and
then comes another v skip this this
music it really takes and and and this
one inch to space is also added not only
do you have boxes in these lists but you
have what they call it what TECA Lou
other people like to think of it as
Springs it's something that something
that can be a little flexible although
this one inch is exactly one inch if
you'd said one inch plus a half an inch
that would mean it has a flexibility to
expand another half an inch in in a
pinch the V skip one inch okay then the
next comes a blank line which would say
end of paragraph except we're already in
vertical mode and so this blank column
doesn't mean anything it's it's it's
just it just looks nice but it doesn't
attack we'll just go right on stay in
vertical mode then comes the letter I
I'll immediately text shifts into
horizontal mode
because we're into a paragraph okay so i
may speak to you and so on and it keeps
on going and all of these are now being
built into a horizontal list in the
meantime Tech has this vertical list for
the page that it was working on but it
set this aside put this on the back
burner and now its attention is turned
to horizontal it's in horizontal mode
and it's going to make horizontal list
eventually later on it's going to of
course finish the horizontal list and
that's going to take it back to vertical
mode and it'll will remember what it was
doing on in vertical mode again and you
can distract it from horizontal mode
into math mode and you can if you're in
math mode you can distract it again and
put it back into horizontal mode if you
wanted to be by saying H box in the
middle of a math formula and then go
back in horizontal mode but pretty soon
it pops back again to mode it was in
when you finish whatever you were doing
on on one more then it then it goes back
and and and and and refreshes its mind
as to where it was where it was when you
got into that mode okay so this is the
basic idea of moes now in here in this
paragraph you'll notice that there every
once a while there's a there will be a
type of graphic error and in fact lambda
is a kind of hard thing to get on some
keyboards I don't know but that's but
now that one of the reasons why most
people then don't type in at the
asterisk is because if it's in a file
then you then it's easier to change the
file and to type everything in over
again each time perfect until you get it
right although if you you know if you
really want to develop your keyboard
skills the it's like you're practicing
the piano or something you could keep on
going until you got it perfect over and
over but but but the fact that but what
you type in after an asterisk does not
get saved in a file it gets put into the
air is temp file and so if you are new
enough about the editor you could edit
out all these asterisks and and and
error messages and and and get it and
get a source file out of it is back but
for the moment you know but that takes a
little bit of work but you can get rid
of all those asterisks if you if you
knew a little
you a little bit about the editor okay
so then we got to the end we got a blank
line here and that said end of
horizontal mode make up the paragraph at
this point technos this whole paragraph
and it will at this point figure out
where to do all the line breaking in the
paragraph it hasn't done lines that one
line at a time it hasn't done any of
those decisions yet because as I said it
optimizes it finds the best way to do it
if there's not if there's a there's a
choice is to bring some words up or down
it it has a neat neat new procedure
which which is one of the things that
that it's not one of the scientific
innovations in tact is a an efficient
way to find the best way to break
paragraphs and there's a long report
coming out of our department about about
why this is so great about line breaking
but it's so long that you might not want
to read it it but I just got so carried
away I couldn't explain it in less than
sixty six pages okay now anyway at the
end of the paragraph it figures out the
best way to break that into lines
according to its criteria known and for
example if you put if you put some
things in there like these this double
arrow to say this is not a good place to
break then it tries to avoid breaking
there if possible so and so on and
there's all kinds of bells and whistles
that you can do to get special effects
than that we probably talk about that
just a little bit later on this week but
that but then at that point it's taking
this paragraph and and convert it into a
whole bunch of boxes and put those into
onto the page and then it goes then
conventus in vertical mode again letter
I again sends it back in the horizontal
mode okay enter the paragraph same thing
so now we come to the end of this
paragraph and then comes H then we're in
vertical mode again now it says H skip
one inch and aha you can't do that in
vertical mode
now that's the that's your most common
error that you get from tech and so we
thought that when we were making up tech
t-shirts we should we should say you
can't do that in vertical mode now or
actually we should think you can't do it
in vertical mode but that always raises
that always raises the question you
can't do what right okay now when you
get this error message the quiz answer
to the question what can't you do is it
I see we're getting a picture of the
audience here so what can't you do and
the answer is the last thing tech is red
is what you can't do okay so when you
look at the error message there will be
it's as I said it error messages on
these two lines the first line is what
it's read the second line of weather
hasn't read so you look at the end of
the first of that line and in this case
it's the age skip this it hasn't looked
at yet it doesn't matter what you said
there what your was the culprit the H
skip okay so that's what you can't do in
vertical mode line so that's a about
entering text after a stop now let's see
I got another example of engine yeah
question are there any perverse error
messages where the problem will have
occurred earlier but the last word yeah
they'll be left up there well okay now
the message that you can't do what is
you can't do something in such and such
a mode that message always indicates
exactly what it says that you can't do
but you might but you're the fact that
you're in horizontal mode might be
because of the error up in vertical mode
might be because of an error that you
made up above like you'll get something
that says you can't do that in math mode
but you didn't really want to be in math
knowledge it's just that you forgot the
dollar sign the end the end the equation
so sometimes you'll make an error but
the error will be up on line 10 but tech
won't see anything wrong until line 13
because everything did make sense they
weigh it you know if you left out the
dollar sign at the end of a formula well
it just looks like a very long formula
and
and there's no way protect to know that
it was that nearly started to be more
meaningful as English text and as a
mathematical formula tech doesn't know
that much about in your yeah I wonder
about when you put this file as you go
over when every line starts with an S
clicks wavy line starts just big
knowledge yeah rather than a in putting
a whole a complete file is the tech look
every time you can put carriage return
or because it seemed that it give you an
answer every after every lines like this
error message so carriage return I don't
quite understand when a carriage return
is very much like a space except that it
will notice took two carriage returns
with Sony spaces between them more who
will be recognized as a blank line I'm
asking if they take interacting with you
when you are inputting the fight that
way and I guess is is okay it's not it
goes in the mouth and it goes into the
hole in n the mouth takes it down to is
coming stomach puts it into the
horizontal list what the mouth actually
does the purpose I didn't describe the
mouth very well the purpose of the mouth
is to recognize special special symbols
as different from others a backslash for
example is there's there's 11 or
actually 13 14 kinds of kinds of symbols
a backslash is one of them are left
braces another one a dollar sign is
another one and and a letter is another
one and and the mouth recognizes those
kinds of those kinds of things and then
it after it swallows these things then
there then what the stomach gets them
it's been classified as as to saying
this was the beginning of this was the
mathematical delimiter that the the the
thing like a dollar signer this was the
beginning of a group like a left brace
or if the mouth sees a backslash the
mouth continues to read for the whole
control sequence and figures out what
what control sequence it is and sends
that to the stomach so the function of
the mouth is to is to convert the the
raw stuff from the outside world into
digestible quantities
which are which are classified as to
saying this is a this is a special this
is something that has some special
meaning the stomach is what actually it
gets in these modes and and when the
stomach gets a letter for example from
the mouth and it was in vertical mode
the stomach says oh and I'm in going to
horizontal mode then it starts to build
a list the stomach's the this distress
final digestion process of the object is
to is building lists so after you typed
in align and hit a carriage return then
the then the horizontal list has gotten
longer by what you typed in that line if
it's part of a paragraph ok but so it's
still sitting there in the horizontal
list it hasn't been typeset in two lines
but it's it's a long list of things
saying this was you know this letter
then this larry miller than his face and
its lair in this letter so i guess my
question is then when is it the
typesetting it typesetting occurs well
ok so after the after you go back in
after you finish the paragraph then the
list is broken into into horizontal
boxes but still is not typesetting those
horizontal boxes are left and put into
the vertical list for the page ok then
the page gets longer and longer and
longer all of a sudden the page is so
long it that is too big to fit on one at
physical page at that point the out
protect output routine gets called into
action and and take out the routine
makes up a box which which is defined
and that that great glorious box is sent
to the output so so it's it deferred
into these long level so you could you
have to think of some other vowels or
something where they wear this output
routine lives but the final box then is
it when it's finally made that's the
that's a box that is made by the output
routine so the text yeah but that's a
little bit beyond the scope of this
course jun you mentioned when you're
discussing center line in that example
that center line essentially was in
itself a definition written in tech is
there any way to easily see those in
other words is it given can you explore
you move down in the stack of commands
given that you know there is something
called centerline to see what the
expansion of that would be yeah it it
appears on error messages that we'll get
to later on so I'll try to remember that
but meanwhile I want to go on yeah so
now here's another example in a simple
example of whether you can't do it error
and this one was that you can't do it in
horizontal mode and this time it was V
skip that you couldn't yell so you can't
you can only eight skip in horizontal
mode and V skip in vertical mode on and
so now let's think about this a minute
and see what it means this was the only
error that one particular person had in
in the file and so in horizontal mode
that means where we are in the midst of
a paragraph okay horizontal mode is when
you're adding to a paragraph and then
all of a sudden of e skip occurred so
what the person forgot was a blank line
at the end of a paragraph before wanting
to do a skip okay because it says that
you because apparently this week
vertical skip of 2.54 centimeters who
was to be actually this is some
scientist trying to say one inch I mean
that's exactly one inch and I think oh
but you know some scientific journals
don't allow you to publish any things in
inches anymore I so anyway so but the
instruction detect it would understand
and a European maybe would also prefer
to say this way ok so now V skip 2.5 47
anyway this is vertical amount of skip
but it's in the middle of a paragraph
you can't do that ok now it tech then
after narrow message does something that
I forgot to tell you about and that is
it gives an upper arrow instead of an
asterisk okay now that there's that's
the other thing that tech will do asking
for instructions the up arrow from is
saying and respond to an error message
this the asterisk means give me some
more input apparel says
you know tell me what to do on error
message well this person said ? what
should i do and i ordered doesn't know
and if you type in something after that
up arrow that that isn't isn't one of
the things tech understands as something
to do after it gives you it reminds you
what what you can do carriage return to
continue line feed to flash error
messages flashing error messages mean a
although it just won't stop anymore
won't give you any of these it won't it
won't stop for prom so just let them run
by until you get to the end and then
there's something about ignoring next
tokens of input that means that you tell
the the mouth to chew up if you type a1
at this point the mouse will chew up one
thing and just and just spit it out and
if you type a nine it would chew up the
next nine things and spin and get rid of
them and for example if i had typed six
here it would chew up 2.5 Force Base see
and then it would stop again and I could
see that the M was ready with was ready
to come in next so that but anyway maybe
you didn't want to have those messy I
cluttered up I is for insertion we'll
talk about that in a minute and ease to
edit if you thi ki a text ops
immediately goes back to the file where
you were on that page 2 line 7 and you
can correct the error right in the file
and start start the whole process over
again and X is the way to stop now it
gives you the prompt again and this time
the person said carriage return and went
on well what happened well when when you
get their message that says you can't do
it in some motor other if and you go on
it just ignores whatever you did it just
forgets just forgets about so this is as
if this be skip didn't appear here so
the 2.54 centimeters is going to be
added to the paragraph okay and so there
was the output introduction 2.54
centimeters the purposes of this paper
is that's interesting too maybe the
purpose of this page okay anyway this is
uh this is what happened then okay now I
know
so that now there were there were there
would have been a way to recover without
going back to edit the file and we'll
talk about that too very soon okay so I
mean one main point is you can't do it
means the last thing that shows in your
our message is what you couldn't do and
he'll be ignored if you give you proceed
okay next the next most common error
that you get is undefined control
sequence okay here's here's an example
of that and again undefined control
sequence' map ins if you give you if you
continue right on after undefined
control sequence then it will ignore the
it will just ignore this the thing that
was undefined and and starting now this
put this in this particular case the
instead of saying input T excl s which
was the filename it just gave the file
name with the backslash and so is
undefined control sequence furthermore
it the control sequence ended at the
period there because it just went up
through the letters and so there was
these there were these two two things
left over Oh point one okay so typing
too at this point says get rid of that
point one see this is the way to delete
something if you know you can be made it
otherwise if you gone on it would see
that point and it would say whoa you
have to define a font first you'd be in
real trouble because we've tried to type
set at period and what you haven't been
find anything yet we're just starting
off this one so the leading to got you
know save that saved a little bit of
time although you know if you could have
started over again since we were at the
very beginning but deleting this
exhilarates what happens if you delete
the next two characters the point in the
one by the way the way the way tech
counts that if you if it's a control
sequence it controls the whole control
sequence only counts as one as one thing
deleted in that case okay now the next
time so after deleting two things it
comes back and gives you another chance
this sub asterisk in parentheses means
it was something you typed in after an
ass
instead of being in a file otherwise i
would say page 297 or something like
that where it wasn't where it was in the
father this is where the the source of
the information was that that the error
was detected in okay so we went on here
and it typed in input.text class you
can't see it again because of this
stupid mistake in tech that right now
Prince eating the top of each other
sorry and then comes undefined control
sequence again page 2 line 6 this is a
silly little test of okay okay now te X
is an undefined control sequence' basic
doesn't have this one in it it was one
of those things that I you know I only
defined in something I'm writing about
tech itself so the logo for TX is not
there and so it will just be ignored if
you if you give you hit if you go on and
so this will say this is a silly little
test of nut of blank right and now again
there's a way to adjust this without
going back and editing the file and this
is the idea of insert and so ill astray
to this by typing I at this point one
thing you can respond to an error
messages I which means insert something
into wherever you are now and so this it
gives you an asterisk again in satx and
that te X got inserted right at the
current place at the end of the insert
then then tech continues with whatever
it was doing so it'll continue with this
period the period is the thing hasn't
been read yet you understand me the
second line this period here has been or
cooked I'd yet so you can see what's
going to come up next so actually so I
inserted the TX and then got the period
and and it continued and in fact the
next error was down on line 16 you can't
do it Nora zontal mode and that was
because we wanted to actually we forgot
a prick blank line before this V skip
okay now again insert is used here to to
fix this up and this is this is a now if
you know that you after you've used tech
for about a week you'll appreciate the
ability to recover from errors i think
but you don't have to you could just go
back and start over again and you know
but I'm just showing you what's
available because once you get used to
it you'll like it one other thing I
dimensional is when i type this te X
here it didn't go into the file the the
other file
that this was coming from this TX CLS
file still says back / TX in it I just
typed it now 22 and to say well I think
I know what's wrong and if i type this
i'll get some some some output and i'll
be able to hit i'll be able to get more
out of this run by catching several
things that was and then this whole
everything you type in is he goes into
the errors temp file so you can use this
as a reference when you're when you're
when you want to make corrections later
so after you've got your output you can
look at your era sponse oh yeah here
with some areas that i could fix up now
and then and then not you you can use
that as a clue as to as to as to as to
how to correct several things at once
because it because for efficiency you
find that died you'd like to not only
correct one thing and then restart tech
again and correct one more thing start
but sometimes you can catch several okay
now here we are you can't do a V
skipping horizontal mode the remedy to
that insert now inserted a power and a/v
skip now I inserted a par to finish the
paragraph p a backslash PA r is just
like a blank line and then i inserted v
skip because this beast dip has already
been been deleted something you can't do
that gets deleted so i put it back in
again so I said v skip again and now
it's ready the 50 points are there and
then it finished the file this right
parenthesis that you see on top of the
asterisk unfortunately should really be
on a separate line is finished the file
so it got to the end of the file and
give you an asterisk so it's not done
yet it's read the file but still once
more the reason is that that particular
file didn't say and didn't save or
refill either so the typing v fill end
got to the end and so it made a nice
little it was actually a very nice
little exercise here but you'll notice
like this one actually tied in it is I
was really delighted to see this because
I tied in most of what I talked about
the first day but you see tech comes out
with it just as te X but we but we did
get it to to recover okay and so it says
I'm trying to test
everything I learned in class today's
notes quote marks you see that you look
at the file it it lists the phone number
there was an H box around here so that
wouldn't break around lines and things
like that and example of an em dash
example of an n dash all these things
were in there they should just long as
you have some extra blanks here and then
some more text you see it all worked out
very fine and the edge and also the arm
recovery did work something okay now um
another kind another kind of recovery
that time to use input was was
illustrated quickly here and that is a I
was trying to help someone and I said
type input paper but it turned out that
it wasn't called paper tech this one was
called Jim Jim Tech and so on and so
unfortunate you can't see this little
bittle say asterisk ji m and so when you
get this message says look up failed on
file paper that tech that means it
couldn't find there's no such file
around here in this computer so you can
insert the real file name you meant so
responding with an i and then you get an
asterisk and then the real file name j
IM now here's something that i just got
to mention you also type a space at the
end of that at the end of a funding tech
is gets confused because filenames have
a strange combinations of characters are
allowed and so in order to know when you
got to the end of the file name tech
likes to always have a space at the end
of every file name space where carriage
return so i typed in ji m space carriage
return and then it started out okay from
jim tekken stand and went on fine until
it got a V skip in horizontal mode again
can't okay I'm a little confused as to
whether the input would have to be typed
again ya know the input actually that
actually that's a good question but but
the input is is already there it's the
it's the paper that didn't get down now
in no but since that's how do you
distinguish that from a case where the
the incorrect command or something that
you can't do is being ignored yeah the
general rule is that the is that the the
the chapter in on errors in the manual
is I think was careful to say for each
error what what will happen next if you
go on and you can't remember all of
those rules though because there are 60
error messages and so so you so I'm
stressing the most common 5 essentially
and those five you can remember how to
recover on in the case of a file name
that you can't find you just type the
file name in again you don't have to say
say why it's looking for the fine it
might be the name of a font or it might
be the name of something else but in
this case the input is already
remembered so if you typed input again
then it would say look up Faolan file
input and then you know it would and
then you'd say oh I guess I don't have
to type input and then and then it would
I think it gives you three chances after
which it gives up something like that
okay next next most common so I told you
the most common areas that you thought
of that you can't do that variety and
the undefined control sequence' in both
of those cases if you go on it just
ignores what was wrong and furthermore
if you insert something it'll be
inserted in place of what was or what
was discarded or what caused the error
ok now the next most common one is
probably let's see number 14 here is
something that you couldn't get that
looks like this missing missing dollar
sign inserted okay and that and this was
on page one line 26 but now here we have
a new feature about error messages and
that is you're getting four lines
instead of two for this error message
and this first line doesn't look too
meaningful just as bad and it looks
rather threatening and it says to be
read again well okay now what happened
is you got to the end of a paragraph and
you end or a blank line in the middle of
them
formula and this is the way tech gets
back into sync it's a lot of time this
is the way it will catch you if you've
forgotten to to put a dollar sign at the
end of a formula then when you get to
the next blank line or the end of a page
or something end of a file page it will
it will say oh you can't you know it
doesn't say you can't end a paragraph in
math mode it says you forgot a dollar
sign okay this is a little more explicit
this time it has some idea as to what
what happened so it inserts it for you
too so when it said in when the error
message says it was inserted that means
it's already recovered something for you
it's already done some points put in a
dollar sign there and then and then now
this two lines is because actually it it
read a paragraph and then it puts
something into one of its lists that was
so funny that tech doesn't even know
what it means so it's called bad and
it's going to read that bad again but it
isn't going to cause any harm so don't
worry about it it's just it's just
printed out there but it will explain
this to be read again in a second anyway
what that meant was and at this
particular example it got to the end of
page one line 26 and and there was just
a freak I don't see that it showed up in
the output actually okay here was
another case display mastered in with
double dollar sign if you started out
something with double dollar sign then
you've got to end it with double dollar
sign you know and a single dollar sign
isn't going to be good enough and so it
it it it corrects it actually it is it
if you go on it'll actually pretend that
there was a double dollar sign there
okay let me see multi-line ever miss it
oh yeah now the next thing is I wanted
to talk about what messages that take
several lines and here is one that takes
three lines so I got it so this will
illustrate maybe almost too much at once
but I think it's okay here is a case you
can do that in restricted horizontal
mode
now all of this I said there are three
modes vertical horizontal and math
actually there's six because there is
there are two flavors of each mode
there's the restricted vertical mode is
not building not not on the top level of
vertical mode not making pages for
output but making put putting things in
vertical direction for a V box for a box
that's that's built inside of something
similarly as a restricted horizontal
mode which is not making a line of a
paragraph but it's making a line for an
H box and then otherwise these woes are
very similar to each other but in this
but this one particular one occurred in
the middle of a center line center line
is building something in restricted
horizontal mall because it's not the
same as a paragraph so ordinary
horizontal mode is a paragraph
restricted horizontal mode is any other
horizontal constructions that you're
doing and and the reason is that you're
not allowed to do it's called restricted
because you're not allowed to do
everything you can do in a paragraph in
the middle of the center line now when
you've got but here I got a message that
describe the air I'm sorry with six
lines not to ok well the bottom one is
the one you usually look at the bottom
one is the one that you typed in your
file so page 2 line 6 is where the is
where the sort where the error really
was and if you look at it but but
sometimes you have to scan up above and
see where see what was done but these
other lines were or things written by
other people and here is the answer to
June's question center line is defined
in terms of something else so what
actually tech did with that it read
center line and then it it read
everything that's going to get fed to
center line so it has already read all
the way to the end of this right brace
and then that that that text was passed
to the center line routine now the
center line routine is expanded here you
can't see all of it though this three
dots means there's something missing at
the beginning and in fact though it's
less it's only two characters worth is
missing and so it's a little bit flaky
there I mean it could have said
centerline anyway center line up and it
takes and it takes one argument
so center line on something and gets
expanded into and then this is the way
center line actually gets expanded so if
you if you really care once you start to
learn about defining control sequences
and you can see what what they are and
somebody said this is the way a center
line actually means it means make an H
box to this up to the current size and
you supposed to Center it that's the way
you do it now then then the argument is
the thing that was that that was this
number one now this all looks pretty
scary at first but I think it makes
sense to me anyway namely this tells you
what tech was reading when it when the
error occurred the last thing at red was
this a st and then the next thing is
going to read is is these on the next
line but there's nothing on next line so
the next thing is going to read it it's
done with this it's that means the next
it'll be done with the argument the
argument was the thing that was passed
to the center line routine so everything
between braces was passed to the center
line routine without the braces and so
the asterisk Scott was petting any of
nothing after that well then we popped
down a level the center line routine
came to the point where it said read
this argument to the center line routine
you know inserted right here so why not
when the center line routine said put
number one in here that main argument
number one goes right there and tech
started to read the argument so after
tech reads this it's going to drop back
and and its next thing it will read is
is the rest of the center line routine
which is this backslash HSS which is a
horizontal stretch or shrink instruction
and then it will read a right brace and
then it will drop back to page 2 line 6
okay so this is what happens when you
when you use a control sequence that's
been defined by somebody else it grabs
up the arguments and calls them number
one and number two and so on and then it
starts to go into the text of the of the
of the that somebody else typed in like
H box to sign and that text couldn't say
it as particular point start reading the
argument and so it gets up higher and
higher levels and then finally it winds
its way down again below the levels the
error message can be quite inscrutable
until you get used to it but the main
thing is first look at the bottom
that tells you where the that tells you
as far as tech read where the error
occurred then look up at the top and
that that's the offending thing that's
what you can't do in restricted
horizontal mode let's hope that makes
sense to you and the answer is yes
backslash AST is something that's not
allowed it's a symbol that's that's a
mathematical symbol so it wasn't allowed
outside of formulas question my question
before was really more aimed at how can
I see these things now it suppose
suppose that I know that there is such a
thing as centerline predefined and I
wanted to see what someone did because I
wanted something was just a little bit
different okay well they look up tracing
in the index of the manual and it tells
you how to trace how to trace macros
okay now um okay the next thing that I
gotta mention is question is yes okay in
that previous one if you'd wanted to
insert this back / ASX would you have
had to pee oh okay yeah that was yeah
good question good question we have this
on the screen again so what could I do i
could say i could say insert here and
then i could then it would give me an
asterisk and then i would insert dollar
sign AST dollar sign and carriage return
and it would continue it would insert
the dollar sign in AST dollar sign and
then then it would it would go on in
fact that's great because i can show you
exactly what happens here it'll pop down
to two different levels of insert this
was this was that when we looked at a
minute ago long ago well it was being
entered blind by line you couldn't do
that in vertical mode okay the presence
at oh I I'm entry skip okay so typed in
I now this person had trouble finding
the backs but the carriage return key or
something but but but inserted not only
V skip which would have been the right
you know insert vfc carriage return it
would have been fine but inserted V skip
11 lambda lambda lambda lambda lambda
okay so that all got inserted in place
of age skip so now tech is reading V
skip 11 a lambda lambda lambda lambda
lambda and then then it will drop down
to the 1 inch and that's shown here on
the next the next the error message it
red V skip 11 landis
ok it doesn't know what those are it has
to be 11 something's and so so the error
occurred the next thing that tech will
read is is this lambda which is
something it's reading again that's what
this reading again means on the on the
level below that it's reading this it
has already read this lambda ok it was
supposed but it was supposed to mean
inches or points or something and that
lambda didn't make any sense and at that
point it said it's an illegal measured
inserted PT into the text and now but it
backs up and it's going to read that
lambda again so that lambda is the same
as this lambda after it's done reading
that one sits on the second line so it's
going to read it again then it's going
to drop down to this one this meant
there's the end of your insert and this
is and then it's going to drop down to
one inch yes question i think the source
of the lambda is it on data media
contour eh which is the way about big
spaces talk oh she's lambda oh I see ok
so this was done on a data media okay
good because I was one ok so anyway
there there it went and so finally what
actually tech red was V skip 11 points
and then a bunch of lambdas which
started a new paragraph and then and
then the a skip had always been already
been thrown away so then he'll say
lambda lambda lambda lambda lambda 1
inch and that will be the beginning of a
paragraph ok and however at the time
this error message occurred it said Ali
illegal unit of measure the person
decided to insert another v skip in the
middle of that and so it added another v
skip and so that UV skip not only 11
points but also another one inch and and
that was inserted even on top of this so
there were four levels of input going on
first is we skipped then the lambda then
these others everything went in and
finally it was in the middle of a
paragraph then are just fine came along
and is this right justified line was
actually contributed to the whole
paragraph and so we had a paragraph that
started out with a whole bunch of things
followed by a right justified line which
was 11 inches long so the paragraph
starts out with a bunch of lambdas and
then it has a and then it has a huge
11 inch box and at this point it doesn't
know how to break that into line so it
says over full box and the overflow box
got in too wide okay now tomorrow we'll
talk about things like over full boxes
which is the next thing that is a big
nuisance okay right
I have this is the first one in this
perspective a joke
what